hello everyone how are you doing up you
guys are having a wonderful day today
we're here with another video and
today's video will be a tips and tricks
method to go ahead and make a decent
amount of money going forward on your
account now this is going to be aimed
primarily at two different types of
people either people that have pretty
much no requirements as in no levels and
can't do anything or the type of people
that have very low cash checks and need
a good money making method going forward
to even start building cash in the first
place so I'm going to go ahead and test
some of these methods and tell you guys
which ones I think are the most
profitable for you and which ones
hopefully fit what you're looking for
best well we'll have a lot of stuff
buying in my grand exchange we want to
focus in here on two things and that's
going to be loop half of keys we have
8.2 K offers for those you can see for
the loop half and then 19.5 Kos and for
the tooth now so overall I spent 27.7 ka
loop into theft now if we go ahead and
put these in its crystal keys as you
guys can see I can go ahead and sell
them for twenty nine two hundred almost
I could even maybe sell them higher
right now but this method literally has
no requirements other than the cash to
be able to buy these now obviously you
don't need to buy a hundred at a time
you don't need to buy two hundred at a
time the more that you can have offers
and four on the grand exchange the
better but you can definitely do these
with only twenty to thirty and make
forty to fifty K every you know a few
minutes here at the grand exchange so
I'm going to go ahead and see how long
it takes me to do these hundred and then
we can find out how much you can expect
to make per hour
so if we go ahead and buy one now as you
guys can see 29.2 case so the hundred
that I was able to do actually ended up
coming out to be about thirty six
hundred per hour I was making about one
per second now my clicks aren't the best
so you could do better than that so I
pretty much invested two point eight mil
and then if we go ahead and take the
total price so I'm able to sell them at
which is around twenty nine two hundred
as you guys can see I pretty much made
150 K and what took me literally a
minute now these do take a little bit of
time to buy surprisingly they are some
of the fastest of the methods that
you'll see here today you can probably
buy upwards or close to maybe a thousand
per hour depending on how many people
are buying them at the moment so while
that method was something that
definitely is fun to do and is really
efficient as far as gp per hour it's
something that you're not going to be
able to do necessarily all the time
depending on how much is being bought
and sold how much you're being undercut
by other players so that should be
something that you have almost in your
grand exchange all the time just kind of
as a passive way to make a little bit of
money so for this next one you're going
to want to go
ahead and try to figure out what herbs
have the best margin upon being put into
unfinished potions basically the way
unfinished potions works is to actually
be able to do something an herb lore you
need to put use the herbs on the vial
and then from there you have to use it
with a secondary ingredient now a lot of
people don't want to do this themselves
because it's kind of a waste of time as
they're not gaining any XP so people
that aren't able to make as much money
in per hour it usually can come to
methods like these as you guys can see
here ran our unfinished potions are
about 7.2 K and the ran ours itself
around 6.9 K as you can see here now
basically what that means is I'm going
to be making about 300g P per herb that
I put into the vial and these are
definitely a really quick way to go
about it now there is one thing you do
have to have the herb lower level that
correlates with the time that you unlock
that herb so obviously you can't go
ahead and do ran ours if you don't have
over 25 so just stuff like that
all right so in a little over six
minutes and 45 seconds I was able to
make a little over 400 so basically at
that rate you guys can expect to get
about 36 to 3500 per hour depending on
how quick or slow you are with it now at
this point it's only right to go ahead
and test and see how much we actually
made on these and the price at which I
bought the rayon ours is 6 and 904 which
means that we are making about 334 GP on
each one of these so now if you have a
lot of these pre button you're making
this much money per hour just by doing
the method itself you can expect about
1.1 to 1.2 mil now obviously that's
reliant on the fact that you have bought
these all they do take a little while to
sell if you're going to go ahead and
sell them at a higher price
you obviously can insta sell them if you
want your money back right away but
you're you're not going to get anywhere
near the same profit that you would have
been considering that unfinished potions
typically have a really high margin now
next up this method does require no
stats at all you just need a little bit
of a cash back to be able to buy
whatever potions you're going to do but
something that makes a decent amount of
money is actually taking four dose
potions and turning them into two doses
now obviously you're going to want to
buy the margins before you go ahead and
just buy the doses because you may
actually lose money now that is one
thing you can also take advantage of
while I would recommend buying potions
and decanting them this way I'd also
recommend buying potions that have a
really low price on one it can actually
gain money by being turned into four
doses something like these super
restores here I'm buying for 8.4 K per
Bordeaux's potion essentially and I can
actually turn them into a 9.2 K potion
so I'm making 800 GP / two that come in
and it really takes no time at all to be
able to turn these into for considering
you can go over to this guy over here
and decant all of your stuff now if
you're buying in four doses and turning
into twos basically what you're going to
want to have is you're going to want to
have an equal amount of vials and
potions for whatever you're doing now
this depends on what you're turning them
into I guess if you're turning them into
two those potions you're gonna want to
have exactly the same number if you're
turning them into one dose potions and
you're obviously going to want to have
double alright so there we go it took me
about four minutes and thirty Seconds to
be able to make 400 of these so a super
strength potion at the time of buying
costs 2077 GP per one that would mean
that you would expect the price of these
to be about 1035 GP however it tends to
be a little bit higher because some
people want to buy two doses for maybe
potentially peeking or stuff like that
so if we put in the price of what one
should essentially equal we get about
103 eight and that's how much you paid
for the four doses so as you guys can
see here that's 416 K and now if we put
them in for what we can actually sell
them for as you guys can see we were
able to make 120k and what was only four
and a half minutes now it is obviously
pretty click intensive and these do take
a little bit of time to sell as you guys
can see it went off pretty quickly but
as you guys can tell so we were able to
make a little over a hundred and twenty
K in the matter of four minutes and
thirty seconds that means that in total
we can make about 1.6 million factors in
the amount of time that it takes to sell
these items but they do sell relatively
quickly and at the same time if you're
buying an item such as these super
restores you can definitely be making a
little bit of additional money on the
side next up as you guys can see we have
bird's nest now bird's nest obviously by
the price you can tell are going to be a
little expensive not too bad though
because you can obviously sell them
pretty quickly but it does require a
little bit of a starting cash pile now
with that said you do not need any
requirements all you need is a pestle
and mortar to go along with it and you
just end up grinding up each one of them
now as you guys saw I spent three 9/64
on all of the birds nests so that was my
buy price now ultimately you're going to
be turning them in to crush bird's nest
so it matters what the buy price of
these are and as you can tell it is 408
- now with that said we're going to be
making about 120 GP per crush 1 now it's
not necessarily one of the best money
making methods per hour but it's
something you can almost always rely on
to have you know a decent margin
sometimes it hops up to around 200 and
you can make around 1 mil per hour or if
it's like right now we're you're only
getting you know 130 or so you can end
up making about 600 K per hour but I'm
gonna go ahead see how long it takes for
me to crush all these birds nests it's
definitely something you could afk if
you wanted to because the pestle and
mortar you can actually afk an entire
inventory however it takes a little bit
longer so I'll be testing it based off
the idea that you guys will be clicking
constantly something I'd recommend for
you guys is using the fill bank feature
basically here whenever you're doing
this it is kind of annoying to have to
individually deposit these birds nests
when you're done so what you're gonna
want to do is take the pestle and mortar
place lot out of your bank fill your
bank and then what as long as you have a
slot for both regular birds nests and
the crush Birds and that's whenever you
press deposit inventory the pestle more
there stays in your inventory and it
definitely
is a nice way to save a little bit of
time and there we go took me a little
under five minutes to be able to crush
all 500 birds nests which means you can
do about 6,000 per hour if you have
decent clicks with that said I was
making a hundred and twenty GP pretty
much per one so obviously that means
that I made sixty K in five minutes now
overall if you go ahead and take sixty K
/ five minutes that pretty much means
that you're being that you're going to
be able to make 720 K per hour so it's
definitely not that bad for having no
requirements at all and on top of this
this is kind of an afk money making
method as well if you don't want to
click and if you don't want to be so
click intensive you can actually sit
there and just do a full inventory you
make like three to four K off the
inventory and it really takes no effort
out of you at all this next method isn't
going to be as much of an hourly method
however it's a really good merch that
you can constantly have that really
takes no risk out of your hands at all
and you definitely make really good
money off of it so basically what I'm
gonna do now is sell off one of these
malediction shards to show you what the
prices of a malediction shard one
so obviously 130 K right there now if
you add that hundred thirty k on to this
shard you then get one point two nine
mil and then if you go ahead and take
the rest of that that pretty much means
that I spent seventeen hundred and
thirty K for the entire malediction ward
itself now the requirements there
absolutely are none other than having a
cash check to be able to put these
together and if we go ahead and look at
what a malediction board is actually
worth you guys can see it's one point
eight six mil which means I'm gonna make
about 140 K now you can probably buy the
parts for these at about one to two per
hour
now that is another 200 to 300 K that
you'll be making per hour on top of that
you can even check out Odeon Ward's
sometimes Odeon Ward's have a better
margin than these but both of those you
want to definitely have in your GE at
all times before people go ahead and
mention how I can't find items to try to
make money off of my own videos that
absolutely isn't the case and I'll go
ahead and dump these right now so you
know that so there we go got those out
of the way but now we have all three
shards I'm gonna go ahead and show you
how I put together these shards now
depending on what requirements you have
personally if you have debts or treasure
unlocked you can use one of these animal
Carl teleports and that's how I'll be
getting there however it's quite easy to
get there even if you don't have that
done go ahead and go to Edgeville you'll
see a lever right here pull that lever
and that'll take you all the way out
here to the deep wilderness now once
you're out here you're going to need to
bring a knife with you as you're going
to slash through the webs right here
once you run east you'll end up passing
by the chaos
until and you're just gonna want to meet
up here if you have the anti Karl
teleport you actually get teleported
right here so it makes it a little bit
faster I'd also recommend to probably
just bringing a statement a dose one
considering you're going to have to oh I
just teleported out here with all this
stuff okay considering that you're going
to have to run a decent amount and it's
probably gonna speed up your overall
time per trip my god Jesus Christ I'm a
savage and all you have to do is simply
run up here to the top of the volcano
and once you're on top and you're on the
bridge you're going to want to go ahead
and use your malediction shards on the
forge itself you can use it on either
side and then without even needing
anything at all the shield gets put
together and you just made 130k
depending on the time that you're doing
this now sometimes I have up to 300 K
margins and that's definitely something
you're gonna want to go ahead and pay
attention to as you can make a ton of
money off of it now overall this took me
a little over three minutes it could
take up to probably about four if you
end up taking the lever route but if we
go ahead and insta sell this and see
what price that were able to get forward
as you guys can see we were able to get
one point eight five which means that we
were able to make about 120 K in a
matter of three to four minutes so now
it's obviously gonna be worth it for you
per hour as that is over two mil per
hour depending on what you're doing so
it's definitely worth the time as long
as you have these offers and you should
be able to get a decent amount over time
and it's definitely something that's
worth it to keep in your grand exchange
slot overall now the final method can be
found under the
lumbridge castle but it does have a
requirement of recipe for disaster now
with that said there are very little
requirements outside of that you put me
practically no cash you can do this with
a thousand coins you can do it with
pretty much anything as the stuff within
the food chest is practically dirt cheap
now with that said you do have to have
parts of recipe for disaster done the
farther you are into it the more food
that you unlock if you're only through
one part you'll have one of everything
available and as you go on you'll have
more and more now basically what you're
gonna want to look for here is grapes
primarily as you guys can see one coin
per one but if you go ahead and look at
the GE price that's 3k just by me simply
and clicking buy 10 just like that but
the thing is you can only hop so many
times per five minutes I believe it's 15
that means that you're gonna have to
spend a little bit more time per world
at least just so that you don't hit that
logout barrier and what I'd recommend
you do is go ahead and buy cooking
apples as they are 72 GP each and they
sell for one and go ahead and buy pots
of flour considering they're 13 GP age
and they sell for a hundred and sixteen
now with that said I'm gonna go ahead
and test
for a little bit and see how much you
are able to make per hour and there we
go a little over five minutes later this
is what I was able to get so as you guys
can see I spent 3000 coins in total to
be able to buy all of this and if we go
ahead and look as you can see no 50k
worth of apples and not too bad we got a
little bit of flour too as well with 20k
and that and 44k there now obviously
that means I was able to make around 110
K in as little as 5 minutes so this is
upwards of 1.2 to 1.3 mil per hour and
it's definitely something that if you
have the question is a really good way
to rebuild your bank right off the bat
like you need pretty much no cash and
this is by far one of the best ways to
go about it now obviously you may have
to sell this stuff for a little cheaper
depending on the times that you're doing
it but overall even then being able to
make about 100k in a little under five
minutes with pretty much no cash
requirement the only thing you need done
as a quest is definitely really insane
and so I would recommend that to anyone
that is rebuilding or has just come back
to the game it needs a little bit of
cash but with that said hopefully you
guys enjoyed the methods today I tried
to be able to cover as many wide areas
as I could at least people that have no
combat skills or people I have no skills
at all and also people that have no cash
so hopefully you guys were able to find
something that works for you I'm sorry
that I sound a little sick today because
it just snuck up on me and I woke up
feeling like absolute garbage but I had
to make a video so hopefully you guys
enjoy if you guys do make sure to leave
a like if there's anything you want to
tell me anything you want me to make in
the future and as far as it pertains to
money making methods let me know about
that in the comment down below in the
comments down below if you guys enjoyed
the content make sure to subscribe to
see it as soon as it goes live in the
future but with that said hopefully get
some wonderful day and peace